hey guys and welcome back to the layer
Heil pen show so I want to talk to you
about the latest Andrew Tate and Tristan
Tay update the leaked documents that
I've seen floating around on the
internet we've all seen the screenshots
of the WhatsApp conversation between two
girls I wanted to get into more detail
give you my opinion on it and understand
what this could potentially mean for the
Tate so let's get into it but just
before we do I am going to be bringing
you more content like this so don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe with the Bell on so you never
miss any of these updates so four days
ago screenshots began floating around
the internet of these two young women
having a WhatsApp conversation and these
are the women that claim to be victims
of the Tate Brothers the first girl was
from the US the second girl was from
Moldova and you can see through these
WhatsApp messages how they talk about
being actresses and essentially how they
plan to set up the tapes I'm going to
bring it up on screen and we can read
through it together so as you can see
these screenshots are the transcripts of
the entire conversation and it starts
two days before the first raid back in
in April 2022 you can see the first girl
starts off by saying you a good actress
question mark so already that's a red
flag why would you ask somebody if
they're a good actress it means
something's fake something's contrived
something not real is going to happen
she then says true Perfecto just play it
cool got it what are they going to be
playing cool act like you don't know
anything just play dumb the other girl
says I'm going to pull some tears out
now we know that she's gonna pretend to
cry so clearly they're going to be
acting she says and play dumb good
advice thank you so they're gonna
pretend to cry and they're going to play
dumb so clearly a lot of acting is going
on here from the two girls claiming to
be victims of the Tates one day before
the first raid one girl says we are
really good and we need an Oscar she
says we need an Oscar which confirms
these girls are acting and they're proud
of the lies obviously we don't know
exactly what they're referring to here
but somebody called the embassy last
year to obviously say something bad
about the taste to say that they did
something illegal maybe after saying we
need an Oscar that's what they're
referring to maybe they just called the
embassy to play victim so if you scroll
down and you can see here the girl says
I told you to be like saying a nice
message that we are hurt or [__] like
that that we do love them we just don't
like the situation so now they're
talking about some kind of complaint
against the taste that they made they're
pretending that they love them but
they're just hurt and they're scared and
they don't like the situation so now we
can see they're discussing the lies that
they told potentially the embassy or the
police whoever it is they're probably
referring to when they were at the
Tate's house they're making up lies that
they're being held hostage at the house
and they're playing the perfect victim
by saying we love them but you know
we're scared come save us and obviously
as an American Girl if you call up the
American Embassy in Romania saying that
you're afraid and you don't like the
situation you're in that's a very
serious allegation and claim so
naturally people are going to respond
straight away and then the next day
there were raids on the house but it's
really interesting if you keep scrolling
one of the girls says play the victim I
mean we are but at like we still love
them and stuff so again confirming that
they're pretending to be victims to
somebody else again we don't know who
this is it could be the embassy the
police were not sure but it is one day
before the raid so it's obviously some
kind of Authority or official so the
second screenshot the conversation
continues and one of the girls is saying
how she's going to reach out to Netflix
Hulu Amazon Prime to basically tell
their fake story about the Tates as they
said they would do in the screenshot
above this is very typical of girls they
obviously want to get as much clout as
possible they want to get Fame they want
to be on TV I think that the Nintendo
swindler came out around similar time
and now all those girls are extremely
famous that's probably what the purpose
of this is you can see from all the
screenshots they're finding it funny
They're laughing yeah babe haha so good
they're loving it they want the clout
and they want the fame this does not
sound like a victim to me this sounds
like two girls who are having a really a
good time enjoying all the media
attention so the second screenshot now
shows the American woman having a
conversation about the situation with
her mother and what I thought was really
interesting was the girl told her mum
that she's not concerned she said
Tristan doesn't really care if I leave
that is so important is one of the
biggest accusations and actually
something that Vice spoke about was that
the women were afraid to leave they took
their passports the women were terrified
well again if this is true the woman is
literally saying Tristan doesn't care if
I leave I'm not concerned I don't care I
feel fine that literally makes the Tates
innocent it literally goes against all
of the claims as you continue to scroll
down it says I don't think they care
much if we leave anyway which is why I
feel okay she just says she doesn't
think the taste would care if she leaves
which is why she feels fine again
doesn't sound like a scared terrified
real victim to me so after she says that
she feels completely safe and fine if
she decides to leave she's now having
this this big argument with her mother
and it's actually really unclear what is
going on she wants to go to London she
has this big argument with her mum but
her mum is clearly very mad at her and
tells her to go to hell for being
arrogant ignorant and she doesn't like
her BS so her mum is clearly very upset
with her behavior perhaps it's to do
with the lying that she's told her mum
she's gonna do so the mother says to the
daughter if you look at the bottom the
whole American Embassy is on alert shame
on you so I guess that does confirm that
actually she did call the American
Embassy and she did lie and the mother
is not happy about that so again if this
is real this is proof that the claims
that were said to the American Embassy
is all fake so just to wrap up if these
documents and the screenshots are real
the conversations between the girls and
the mother then it means the takes are
entirely innocent because the entire
case is based off of this the Tates held
women against their will back in April
last year so however at the end of the
day we don't know where they came from
we don't know how accurate they are but
to me they look real to be brutally
honest how do I know I'm not an
investigator but they look like real
conversations to me so moving forward I
think these documents should probably be
admitted to a judge or the judge that's
in charge of this case so that they can
decide whether they're real or not and
then let the Tates go because there's no
evidence also what is really interesting
is I found this on spy news they're a
random Romanian news Outlet only spy
news are covering this which is really
interesting to me because whenever
something's released which is negative
about the Tate the BBC Vice CNN they're
always the first to talk about it but
now there's something which is positive
and could actually prove The Taste to be
innocent that comes out and just only
one little Romanian news Outlet is
covering it funny how that works so I
hope that these screenshots will be
admitted to a judge so a judge can look
at them make his own decision and
hopefully let the Tates go and realize
that everything was all a lie guys I'm
gonna be following all of this so don't
forget get hit the like button and
subscribe and I will see you all on the
next video